amore amore dio
[Musica]
quando poi ti lascio la colazione pronta
più preparato anche con scarica ti
aspetto ehi tu sì dico proprio tecnica
di sbagliare che sono già meno 10 è alza
che subito buttati nella doccia e questa
stamattina dalla colazione non la fai
perché ti sei svegliato troppo tardi
cavoli tuoi comprai una merendina hai
capito bene che cosa devo fare
ciao mamma amore dove vai
vado a fare un giro in centro con le
amiche
va bene amore mi raccomando fai la brava
divertiti e goditi la tua gioventù a
dopo va bene a dopo ciao mamma no scusa
dove stai andando vado a fare un giro in
centro con amiche e tu pensi di uscire
vestita così con tutta la pancia di
fuori ma rita impazzita e ti voglio
ricordare che solo 15 anni corni subito
in camera infatti a coprire mamma ho
finito la marmellata posso buttare il
vasetto ma morì mio certo che puoi
buttare il vasetto
cosa vuole che faccio ai video vasetto
di vetro time però mi raccomando buttano
nella differenziata perché questa è una
famiglia ecologica noi rispettiamo
l'ambiente
mamma ho finito la marmellata posso
buttare il vasetto buttare mamma ma ti
sei impazzita non lo sai che tua mamma
usa i vasetti di vetro per piantarci
erbe aromatiche in questa casa non si
butta niente si può riutilizzare tutto
ok lo lascio qui hai qualcosa da fare
per caso si mamma adesso ti porto tutto
solo due minuti che finisca una cosa
quel telefono donna inaugurino
tranquilla marina di mi hai della roba
da lavare che devo fare la lavatrice
dopo the rapporto fammi finire qua un
attimo o ravel ad evitare che poi inizia
la telenovela non ho tempo da perdere
manna dove è la pasta e siri amore
allora sei tu apri frigo ecco nella
parte alta a destra se non sbaglio al
terzo al quarto ripiano ci dovrebbe
essere un piccolo contenitore verde
acqua con le pecore più con i bisogni di
gianluca marino
ecco lì dentro c'è la pasta ok trovato
mamma
dov'è la pasta è lì nel frigo e non la
vedo hai dentro un contenitore non c'è
nessun contenitore non c'è nessun
contenitore perché tu non lo sai cercare
come al solito è sempre bisogno della
mamma
voglio amore mio ti sei bruciata ma devi
usare la paletta per girare la piadina
con le mani brodo con la paletta spoglio
ecco lo sapevo ti sei bruciata ma io
voglio dire ma 15 anni è normale che tu
non sai neanche girare una pedina è
guarda che non ci sarà sempre tua madre
ad aiutarti a farti le cose devi
imparare e mi dispiace dice bruciate
adesso ti passerà che ti devo dire
almeno impari la lezione mamma che
guardi niente amore sto guardando un
noiosissimo talk show ma piuttosto
parliamo di te è come è andata oggi a
scuola
bene hai voglia di dirti qui a
raccontare tutto a mamma
dai vieni mamma che guardi silenzio è
possibile fare vi sempre nei momenti più
importanti e stai zitta perché adesso
marilena sta per scoprire che christobal
la gradisce ha capito e ha mai visto
banca e non ma io sono pieno amore
tranquilla fa niente se non ce la fai
più
te lo conservo e lo mangi poi stasera va
bene mamma
io non ho più fame sono pieno 96 piena
ma se non hai mangiato niente non ti
vergogni è di avanzare tutto questo cibo
quando in africa i bambini muoiono di
fame di reati vergognare e adesso lo
finisci tutto fino all'ultimo chicco di
riso se non avessi mai più carino mamma
io sto male
amore mio stai tranquilla adesso chiamo
subito il dottore e poi avviso scuola
che tu oggi non andrà elezione la tua
macchina si prenderà cura di te
due uomini è il calduccio 41
mamma sto male mi sento tutti i brividi
ma quali brivi avrai semplice
raffreddore adesso non esagerare è
adesso sai cosa faccio vado a preparare
un bel infuso di zenzero echinacea
arnica e limone e chi passa tutto
tu però alzati e muoviti preparati che
deve andare a scuola non penserai mica
che ti lasci stare a casa per un
raffreddore
[Musica]